hi everybody my name is nia and today we
are going to be going through
the six things you need to do before
starting
coding boot camp so you make sure you
just hit the ground running
and have the most enjoyable smooth
process as possible switching into
software engineering
so let's get to it number one
the first thing you need to do before
coding bootcamp
is quit your
job it is i
truly want want to say impossible
to have a job whether it be full-time
part-time contract just weekends
it is impossible to have a
job and still go through coding boot
camp
with ease and without falling behind in
any way
so you need to quit your job because
even if you're just
only working weekends you need those
weekends
for me coding boot camp was about 40
hours
of class time so we would you know be in
class or be working on lessons
from nine yeah nine to five
and sometimes actually like nine to six
depending on the day
but if you're you know rusty on
something or you're not understanding
something
that's more hours need to put in if it's
you know project week or you're
you know building an app or you know
enhancing your portfolio through the
boot camp
that's a weekend you need to spend
really putting your all
into these projects into these apps into
these lessons to make sure
you don't fall behind and you have the
best shot possible
of leaving that boot camp with a job
and so it is impossible
to have a job now i know you know people
you know some people watching those
would be like oh well i had a job
and you know i did it because of x-ray
like that's
great it is but
it is don't have a job just don't have a
job i didn't have a job
um i actually you know moved into my
parents house but like that's all
that's gonna come later but just don't
have a job
please number two the second thing you
really need to do
before starting coding boot camp is save
up money now you know you don't have a
job now
so how are you going to support yourself
so
you need to have money saved up either
money saved up
or have a spouse that is willing to
you know now be kind of like the sole
um income provider or you have you know
parents you can go to friends et cetera
people who can help support you now
because you don't have a job
and you shouldn't try to start getting
one while you're in boot camp so you
need
income somehow coming from somewhere
and so let's say you don't have those
other options whether it be
parents or a spouse that is in a
position where they can support both of
you
and everything you need to have saved up
your
money before starting boot camp how much
money
that depends on the length of the boot
camp because my boot camp was four
months but i
have seen others that are six to a year
most boot camps are either
three to four months six months a year
so
that's all going to depend on the length
of the program
and it's even better if you are single
because then
if you do have a spouse then that's you
know it
sucks having to have somebody else be
the person to kind of pick up
you know to kind of um hold up the fort
you know for you guys but you know that
is what marriage is about but i'm just
saying
save up as much money as you can before
starting
your boot camp number three the third
thing you need to do
is write a letter to your friends
and your family during these
next few months you are going to be
unavailable in a way that
i'm thinking most people are not used to
and i'm talking about the people close
to you if your family are you know
they're used to seeing you every weekend
you're you know your spouse is used to
seeing you you know
every day every other day you have
friends you have you know siblings
you need to write them a letter to just
one thank them for supporting you on
this new journey that you're on
and two just ask and beg for their
patience
with you while you go through this
because it is so hard for
you but it's also so hard for the people
around you because
now they have to shift their life
because they're not used to
you know going days without seeing you
going days or weeks without talking to
you
so you need to be able to give them a
letter and
ask them that whenever they're
frustrated with you or whenever they
feel
lonely or anything like that to read
that letter and just remember
the big picture in all of this and why
you're doing this because at the end of
the day it's
for all of you guys so just try to just
prepare them as much as possible
beforehand
tip number four so you just wrote a
letter to your friends and your family
now write a letter to yourself
yes you because
you are going to get so frustrated
during this journey
you are going to at some point think you
are just not cut out to be a software
engineer
or a web developer or a data scientist
etc
you are going to think you're just not
cut out for it and
feel like the dumbest person in the
room and feel like you know you can't
even ask
certain questions because they're just
too you know dumb or
you should have known this already in
all of this write a letter to yourself
and thank yourself in that letter for
having the strength and the courage
to go on this process and demand a
better life for yourself and then
just give yourself some kindness some
love just say look if you're reading
this you know you obviously
are going through it right now like keep
going like
you are a strong person odds are this
isn't the toughest thing you've ever
gone through through
your life odds are you have faced
adversity throughout your life
for something remember that remember
that you got through x
y and z and so you can definitely get
through
this because where that other thing you
know
was something that was you know
upsetting and it was
negative this is positive and will
enhance your life so much in the coming
months and years and so write a letter
to
yourself and make sure you go back to it
when not if when you just
feel like you just can't continue on
this journey read it read it again and
again okay it is so important so
important be kind to yourself and just
be patient so before getting to
tip number five i'm going to ask for you
to please
hit the subscribe button if you've liked
what you've heard so far
if this you know isn't your first video
and hit the like button if you like the
tips you've heard so far and if you'd
like me to
produce more content like this because
i'm really trying to make sure i am
being a resource for
you all to make sure that more people
are able to have a smooth transition
in this new career path so please help
me out by doing that
and let's get back to it so tip
number five establish your own
working space during this coding
bootcamp
you want to make sure that you have a
space
where you have really like full control
over what's around you you have full
control over the volume
who is in and out of it and everything
because
you are going to be spending countless
amount of
out outwards
going through it with these lessons with
these projects with these teachers with
these
webcasts with like it is just so
much and so you want to know that when
you sit
in that chair that you know is part of
your workspace
you can get into a certain mindset and
you can
you know just block everything else out
and focus on
the tasks at hand for me i had moved
back in with my parents so that
i wouldn't have you know bills to worry
about and you know i
had quit my job didn't have a job and so
i
was relying on them you know for that
support
and all of that and for me my you know
space was the basement
and that's where i did all of my work
that's where you know i rested and all
of that
and if i didn't have that it would have
been very difficult
to have had as smooth
a as smooth of an experience
that i did because y'all i have a
seven person household the youngest
person in my house
is two years old the oldest person in my
house is 82 years old
so it would have been very difficult to
keep
on focusing and getting through it and
so even if you have you know a one
bedroom apartment a studio apartment and
you live with a spouse or a girlfriend
or just another person
just put aside a side a corner for
yourself that would be your own
sanctuary
buy some dividers that you know now you
can block
off you know a certain you know side of
the room or like
now when you're there then you know
people can't see you and everything
because it's also hard to work when you
know people are looking at you
and all this so just try to find a space
for yourself that you can just devote
everything to that way like i said you
sit in that chair
and the whole world disappears you are
working so
that is tip number five so tip number
six
yo break up with
him break up with her break up with
them if they are not a supporting
partner you
are going to have such a rough time
during this experience now
i'm focusing more on the people who are
let's say
dating someone i'm speaking less about
spouses
but you know if you have a spouse and
you know you've been thinking about it
for a while like you'll remind this age
and operate like do what you need to do
do what you need to do but no overall i
am you know
kind of joking kind of not if i
if i think about the relationships i've
been in in the past
this is we're getting we're getting deep
y'all if i think about the relationships
i've been in in the past there are some
that i
know i would not have
succeeded the way i did if i had been
with them during this process
i would not have because the amount of
support
it takes for you to go through this
you are not going to be as you know
attentive to your partner you're not
going to be as
as freely available to them as you may
have been
before and it's going to be hard for
them
watching you pay more attention to your
computer screen
and your peers on the other side of it
and your teachers on the other side of
it
than them when they're just four feet
away from you it's going to be
difficult so if you have a relationship
that
you you know has has been rocky
and you know you know i know some people
are watching this and they know that
their partner is not a supportive person
one
[Music]
you should kind of break up with them
i'm not going to tell you what to do
i'm not i'm just saying the six tips you
know that
really i believe from my
from my experience would help
you succeed throughout this transition
if you are not with a supportive partner
it's going to be so difficult for you
we always said during my coding bootcamp
one of my instructors
would constantly say the spouses are the
real
mvps of this coding bootcamp because
it's
them that now have to take on the extra
weight of you know
being the sole provider because you know
you quit your job
and it's them that has to you know they
support you and to see you frustrated
and you know see you upset and have to
really you know
encourage you to keep going it's them
that helps you keep your head straight
so you can
have this better life for you and them
and the people you care about
and so if you are with a person
who isn't that for you and by now
you know i'm sure you know if they are
that or not if
if you don't know because you know maybe
it's been three minutes since y'all you
know sat at the table
you're going to know very quick once you
start this boot camp if they're
supportive or not
and if you see that they're not
supportive like when you're in the boot
camp
you see that you are now falling behind
you are now
finding it so difficult to concentrate
because of this
i am a person who always says
to advocate for yourself first put your
own
mask on before tending to somebody else
and i'll leave it at that i'll leave it
at that and like i said half of it you
know
it's kind of a joke but half of it isn't
you need a support system okay
so make sure you have that
so thank you so much for getting through
this with me
please subscribe if you know you've
liked the videos you've seen so far
and look forward to more because i
really want to expand this community
and allow youtube to just you know show
my videos to more people so
thank you so much for joining me today
and i'll see you
soon